so here we have a sample of barium so
barium is going towards the bottom of
the group 2 or alkali metals so this is
a rod of barium we've gotten here okay
so what I'm going to do I'm going to
hopefully and get the top off it's
really hard I've got four pairs of
gloves on here so it's all quite hard
everything is very very difficult to
move I want to put it down for a second
barium is a heavy element I believe that
this is a some sort of barium all and
it's really heavy piece of mineral much
heavier than you might expect
seeing its size and I found this just
lying around well on the walk somewhere
I think it may be barium sulfate but I'm
not a mineralogist
so and maybe completely wrong but it's a
nice piece and I have it as an ornament
in my office I'm hoping it'll come out I
have there we go so that's the end of
our rods of barium so what we can do is
beings quite soft so we should be able
to file a little bit of barium off and
we do that so we have some very
important material so we can react it
with things and make barium compounds
there it is so this is a hundred gram
Robert Rada barium I don't think we've
used too much that there probably is
close on 100 grams there because barium
is a heavy element it has quite an
important medical use because heavy
elements scatter x-rays so that if you
shine x-rays on a solution or suspension
of barium it looks black and because the
x-rays don't go through so if you want
to take pictures of the soft part of
somebody's body it's easy to take
pictures of their bones but if you want
to look at their gut or their throat or
their intestines they don't show up on
x-rays so you feed them what is called a
barium meal if they take it through
their mouth or a barium enema if they
take it through the other end and you
pump in quite large quantities of some
barium salt and then when you x-ray them
the part that's filled up or just has
been coated with it
looks black or white if you look at the
x-ray and negative which people quite
often do so it's very useful for a
fairly straightforward x-ray imaging of
people's bodies have you ever had a
barrier
fortunately not it's not meant to taste
very nice I think they put peppermint or
something into it to pretend that you're
enjoying it but drinking a large
quantity of barium I think is not
enormous fun and people use barium
because it's really non-toxic if you
took that amount of lead or mercury you
might get a better picture but you'd be
dead so what we should be able to do
hopefully because this barium is soft we
should be able to file a little bit of
the barium onto this foil this is why
I'm hoping to do you see if I'm a girly
girl now oh my can see that bits coming
off actually they're very very small so
they're very sad that was a bigger bit
so I'll show you this again in a minute
but you can see how we're kind of signed
to clean off the surface so we can't
taking that tarnished layer off many
elements suddenly become fashionable and
in the 1980s late 1980s barium became
fashionable as one of the components of
the so called high-temperature
superconductors the superconductor is a
material which has zero electrical
resistance and people discovered that
the compound of barium yttrium and
copper very metrium cuprate and related
compounds when they were cooled to
liquid nitrogen temperature 77 degrees
absolute minus 196 centigrade became
superconductors Oh
apart from shaky hands so I've got
hopefully some very sort of fine barium
turnings now so you can see that okay we
have a little bit of tarnish in there
but also there we have you know quite
shiny luster as well on some of the bits
so there's my barium nitrate and again
I'm going to add some of my combustion
mixture now we're using the energy of
that combustion of the sugar to excite
the barium so that we can observe its
emission spectrum or the flame test
color again pour it out onto a heatproof
mats so again
so this time again we saw the same
exciting chemical reaction we saw that
same exothermic reaction lots of co2
lots of steam again but this time the
flame was colored green and this is the
characteristic Apple green which is
associated with barium salts so much
more exciting flame test all the
elements in this group group to have
fluorides that are insoluble and they're
very nice materials they look like glass
and you can put them in water and they
don't dissolve and this is extremely
useful for technique called
infrared spectroscopy where you're
putting essentially heat rays through
some sort of liquid to measure the
spectrum how the light is absorbed and
especially if you're using water or
something that's wet salt of calcium
fluoride barium fluoride are really good
for making the windows he is quite a
large window you can see my eye through
it this one unfortunately is cracked so
it's no use anymore this is calcium
fluoride and calcium fluoride is much
cheaper than barium fluoride so you can
get away with it you use calcium
fluoride for an experiment the problem
is that calcium ions are quite light and
the fluoride and calcium ions vibrates
in the crystal through thermal energy
and these vibrations absorb infrared
light barium is much heavier so barium
fluoride vibrates more slowly and so it
absorbs much longer wavelength light so
in a particular experiments if you need
to get that region of a spectrum you
have to go for barium fluoride in state
I tried calling one of my colleagues in
the other office see if you had a piece
of barium fluoride a barium fluoride
window can't find it so you can see
calcium fluoride barium fluoride will
look exactly the same but honesty makes
us say this is not bearing fluoride so
we have this one big blob
and we have the finely divided barium as
well okay we're going to try and put
that in water and see how it reacts
okay so what's happening is we are
seeing the barium reacting with water I
think our big blob is still going
actually the bearing is reacting with
the water or doing is producing hydrogen
gas and what I think is probably barium
hydroxide so that's what's precipitating
out of solution